We're here with the incredible firefighter,
Kat Lewis, and the rest of the Long Beach Fire Department
and their loved ones.
(applause)
Okay, before the break, we watched the surprise,
When we told them that we were going to make
their firehouse over,
Drew Crew member, and my design partner in crime
Mikel Welch, and I planned out every single inch
of their new space together.
So, oh gosh, I hope you like the end result.
Check out what happened when Mikel
came to reveal what we had worked so hard on.
Oh God.
(upbeat music)
I'm here at a firehouse to surprise some lucky fireman.
And in particular one lucky firewoman.
I just wish there was some easier way to get downstairs.
(cheering)
I'm Mikel from the Drew Barrymore show,
and Drew sent me here
to help you guys out with a fantastic make-over.
This is a very important project,
not just to Drew, but to myself as well,
because my brother's a firefighter.
So are you ready to see the space?
(cheering)
Let's go check it out!
Alright, Kat, bring those boys in.
Wow.
Oh my.
Look at that.
This is awesome.
Wow.
A little bit different, huh?
(cheering)
Well, we really wanted you guys to have
a awesome recreational space
where you can just chill and relax.
So, Drew and I want to give a huge shout out to Burke decor
for providing furniture to deck out this entire space.
Check out the beautiful Camile dining chair,
it's perfect for this area.
We kept the original dining table,
but we brought in these beautiful Rowen dining chairs.
We use some of Drew's paint, Flower Home.
So we've got white Daisy on the top of the wall,
then soft black on the bottom
to really finish out the space.
Now, before, I don't even know
how you could see the carpet, it was so dark.
So, Drew and I have given you some beautiful carpet
just to brighten up the room a little bit.
So remember you had those red partial drapes up here.
Well, now we've given you some beautiful Roman shades
that go all the way down.
It's going to keep the sunlight out,
and best of all gives you full coverage.
Now, Kat told me you boys can get a little messy at times.
So we've given you closed storage, which will help
keep these high traffic areas clear and organized.
I know this wall right here is really important.
So we wanted to put up several Fireman's hats.
This pays homage to them on this wall,
but it's actually a cool installation, I think.
I know one of the things that you guys really needed,
was a coffee bar.
Well you had a coffee bar,
but it wasn't like a coffee coffee bar.
Well, we've decked out a completely
furnished coffee bar, as you can see here.
(cheering)
And if you look all the way on the end,
that's not a microwave, my friends,
this is a air fryer and toaster
from the Beautiful line by Drew Barrymore.
Drew and I really wanted to
give back to you and your community,
and we hope this gesture will make things better.
At least give you a nice place to come and relax.
So, I think the main question here
is to Kat, did Drew and I pass the test?
Oh my God, absolutely.
This is honestly incredible.
It's better than I think we could've wished for.
And I know I speak on behalf of the entire team,
when I say we are very thankful and appreciative and-
(clapping)
Let's enjoy the space!
Everybody pick a chair!
I've got my usual spot.
Yeah, this is his spot.
Look at these guys, already!
This is nice.
Thank you, Drew!
(applause)
Mikel and I really kind of were inspired
by a little bit of a hotel look, if you will.
And hotels are very sleek and chic,
but looking around your space,
you need a lot of comfortable cozy seating.
So, we just went with like big furniture
that you could sink into and feel really comfortable.
Lots of seating, whether it's at the dining room
or along the walls in front of the TV,
and your beautiful photographs
and your ever so beautiful fire helmets.
We wanted to incorporate that into the space,
in an artistic way, to honoring your history
and where you've been and where you're going, so.
Drew, speaking of helmets,
the helmet is an integral part of our equipment.
And since you were so gracious to
donate a renovation to our firehouse,
we wanted to do something for you.
Sam, can you come down this way?
(applause and cheering)
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
I am so humbled and honored to wear this
and honor you guys.
That's what Mikel and I wanted to do,
was give you a space worthy of you.
Thank you so much for including me.
(applause and cheering)
Thank you Kat Lewis and the rest of the
Long Beach Fire Department,
thank you to my best partner in design crime,
Mikel Welch, and a big thanks Burke Decor,
because they really provided everything.
And there were things we were trying to get
and we couldn't, and Burke Decor
completely saved the day, and everything
looked exactly to our specifications.
So thank you.
(outro music)